ola asks is there a need for a
maintenance period after a bulk to make
sure that the mass stays on
so this is looking instead of saying hey
do i need maintenance phases during cuts
this is after a bulk do i need a
maintenance phase to kind of solidify
that new muscle tissue before i can you
know transition into the next fat loss
phase or cut
my answer would be no
this is a common recommendation and i
wouldn't be shocked if i've potentially
suggested something along these lines in
the past
you know way back
but after you know putting a lot of
thought into it i think this is probably
just an illusion
that is popular because it's a
common and generalizable illusion so at
the end of a bulk we're often kind of
watery and bloated and we're all beefed
up
we're usually like pretty over fed
so we're in a position where we are
really at an inflated body weight just
due to water weight and gi content and
things of that nature
and in many cases our total daily energy
expenditure is also a bit inflated as
well just because in the context of over
feeding sometimes we do have an adaptive
process where we up regulate our our
total daily energy expenditure so we're
in a kind of unique state at the end of
a pretty serious bulk where we're
pushing the food intake pretty hard
now
sometimes people will shift
straight from that state where they're
bulking into a cut
and it'll have a huge drop in calories
there will be a huge initial drop in
scale weight uh you know your carb and
sodium intake go down uh maybe glycogen
shifts a little bit drop in water weight
less gi content because you're going
from over feeding to underfeeding and a
lot of people see that initial drop in
scale weight and they say wow i just
lost a tremendous amount of muscle in
reality that has nothing to do with
muscle loss
and muscle loss in that scenario is
pretty unlikely if you're if you're
putting together your diet effectively
and another thing that that kind of
contributes to that is
a lot of people do have a tendency
myself included back in the day to
overestimate muscularity during a bulk
uh i remember
thinking i was just putting on pure
muscle until a roommate was like dude
you've you've gained a tremendous amount
of fat and i i think someone needed to
tell you and no one would yeah uh but
it's a impromptu intervention yeah i was
totally certain that all the weight i
was gaining was muscle and he was like
yeah it's
maybe 15
uh so so that actually is really common
though like if you talk to someone who's
who's been bulking and just kind of
recreationally bodybuilding and you say
how many pounds do you need to lose
before you're going to be shredded
a lot of times they'll say 20 when the
number is 40. like when we bulk we have
a tendency
because you know things are going well
the scale is moving we're getting
stronger sometimes we have a tendency to
overestimate the amount of muscle we're
putting on and to underestimate how much
fat would need to be lost to get to a
particular physique that we have in mind
uh and so i think that there's a
compounding effect there where people
they do that initial abrupt change from
a bulk to a cut
body weight drops really quickly and
they think i think i just lost a lot of
muscle
and they decided on the front end i'm
going to lose 20 pounds in this cut they
lose their 20 pounds they aren't as
shredded as they thought they would be
and they say you know what happened i
lost all that muscle the first couple
weeks that's why i'm not as shredded as
i thought i would be 20 pounds lighter
so i think there are a couple different
types of illusions that are kind of
contributing to this idea that you need
to do maintenance to kind of solidify
that muscle before you transition to a
cut but at the end of the day i cannot
think of a single physiological reason
that you would have to take that
approach i can't think of a mechanistic
explanation of why that would be
necessary but i can think of a couple
practical reasons why someone might
prefer that so first of all like i said
it can
it can be quite a drop when you go from
fairly aggressive over feeding to fairly
aggressive underfeeding uh and so if you
wanted to have kind of a smoother more
predictable transition
at the beginning of your cut just in
terms of scale weight it might make
sense to go from over feeding at the end
of your bulk to a little maintenance let
things kind of settle see exactly where
you're at in terms of body weight and
then initiate the cut you might just get
some smoother transitions in terms of
scale weight that aren't quite as
jarring
and another practical benefit would be
like i said sometimes with over feeding
during a bulk we will see that total
daily energy expenditure is not just
high but inflated you know there's an
adaptive increase and so you might want
to you might consider it to be very
practical and helpful
to drop down to maintenance
and kind of see where your cat calories
settle there
uh and then use that number to inform
your first calorie drop when you
transition to a cut so there might be
some practical benefits that make the
process a little bit more predictable um
but but in terms of physiological
benefits i truly can't think of any uh
so so it's it's a viable option but i i
don't consider it to be a
a requirement or something that is
necessary